welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and black panther what kind of
forever introduces the MCU Namor or
Namor actually I really should say
introduces the MCU to Namor because
without spoiling anything whatsoever
about this movie's plot knowing that
this Submariner has been swimming
underneath our feet tickling them is a
pretty dramatic shift in the hierarchy
of power of the MCU and yes I understand
I look and sound a bit different I'm
back at new Rockstar's HQ recording this
video right now I'll be back in the
camera setup that you're more familiar
with in the next video you see me on
anyway ahead of wakanda forever's
release Marvel Studios released the
first episode of a podcast series hosted
by author and black panther Comics
writer tadahasi coats in which he
interviews Ryan coogler about the
devastating moment Google learned about
Chadwick Boseman passing away his
decision whether or not to recast and
other thoughts heading into the sequel
it's an amazing podcast series I highly
recommend you check out this first
episode and while the first episode's
out now the remaining episodes will drop
in the new year and at the very end of
this podcast there was a quote from
Marvel had given feige in episodes to
come presenting interesting questions
about his bigger plan for Namor in the
MCU you know people who read the comics
know that there's 80 years of of stories
with Namor that we can tap into where
and when we'll keep to ourselves for now
but we think that this is an incredibly
iconic character that's being introduced
probably to most people most moviegoers
for the first time and we very much
expect them to want to see more where
and when Spike is referring to the fact
that Neymar was one of the very first
Marvel characters introduced back when
the company was still called timely
comics in 1939 alongside Golden Age here
is like the Human Torch Neymar is
referred to as Marvel's first mutant
because he was technically called a
mutant and he predated the X-Men by like
20 years indeed there is over 80 years
of Marvel history to look at for name or
story lines but we should be honest not
all 80 of those years were filled with
amazing name or storytelling that will
make good movies particularly since the
MCU is fully reconceeding the character
with a specific cultural background even
opting to rename his home from Atlantis
to talocon he's not really Marvel's
Aquaman in fact it would be more
accurate to call Aquaman DC's Neymar but
either way there are only so many comic
story lines I would be looking at when
he's saying things like where and when
the mcu's not more diverges from Source
material arguably more than any other
MCU character and Peggy I think is
hinting that throughout the history of
the 616 MCU that we've been living in
Namor has been beneath it all and he's
ready to rise up as a new leader of the
mcu's mutant opposition I can recommend
a few name more comics arcs to dig into
for the immediate known future the MCU
definitely check out Jonathan Hickman's
run of the new Avengers of 2015 which
leads into time runs out a Prelude two
secret Wars Marvel Studios is definitely
pulling from this paraphrasing pretty
closely everything Reed Richards told us
about incursions and Multiverse of
Madness and the screenwriter if I get
hired to write that dialogue is Michael
Waldron who also kind of introduced Kang
into the MCU through his variant and
Loki and is writing the script for
Avengers Secret Wars now in this era of
the comics Neymar is a member of the
Illuminati in a bitter rival to Black
Panther after Neymar who had previously
been possessed by the Phoenix force in
The Avengers vs X-Men storyline flooded
the nation of wakanda now wakanda in the
movie is flooded by namo's horses but
the conflict behind it is something very
different perhaps the most popular name
or title from the recent era it's 2009's
Submariner The Depths this is by Peter
Mulligan and art by Assad ribik the
artist Taiko otiti completely lifted the
image of valigar from 4th or 11 Thunder
some Mariner The Depths depicts Neymar
as a third-person horror threat against
human sea explorers very similar to the
way Namor is initially introduced in the
wakanda forever film there's also Neymar
or King and black from really the past
couple years it's a pretty great
storyline that faces Neymar off against
a group called The Swift tied a story
that explores Antarctica I just wonder
if that might have come out after Marvel
Studios started to craft their vision
for nemour's future in the movies truly
it seems like Marvel Studios is most
interested in namora's status as a
mutant and if the MCU is really
embracing that whole genetic side of the
character that might really tell us
about the where and when feige is
referring to specifically the way no
more intersects with the history of
mutants in the past Decades of the 616
MCU and around the globe this video is
brought to you by the ridge the ridge
wallet is like
sleek and Industrial it's designed to
fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky old school wallets and make you
look like you're smuggling an 80s car
phone in your back pocket check it out
there are over 30 colors including
carbon fiber invert titanium it holds up
to 12 cards and still has room for cash
card
and gold dollars this is what they call
the black Damascus only the finest for
my front pockets every Ridge wallet
comes with a lifetime guarantee and
they'll let you test drive it for 45
days and send it back for a full refund
if you don't love it the wallets have
over 40 000 5 Star reviews it's made
with an RFID blocking technology that
protects you from those digital
pickpocketers they also have other cool
products like this commuter backpack
it's weatherproof and great for toting
around a laptop this month actually
marks nine years since the ridge started
and they're celebrating with a special
sale so get 15 off today with free
worldwide shipping and returns by going
to ridge.com new rockstars that's
ridge.com new rockstars and use code new
rockstars find the link in the video's
description now I am going to get asked
about this so I should go ahead and
clear it up did the undersea earthquake
said Okoye mentioned in Avengers end
game refer to any drama with no more
twizing mild subduction under the
African plate do we have a visual how
are we handling it it's an earthquake
under the we handle it by not handling
it well Ryan coogler did an interview
with Aaron Green from comicbook.com and
phase zero God bless Aaron for asking
him this question did they ask you about
the part in Avengers in-game where they
talk about the earthquake under the
water and the drama popping off
underneath I actually I asked him I was
like hey what's going on there and they
were like oh just an earthquake I got my
own theories about what it what it was I
I imagine that maybe had something to do
with Chloe Jaws film eternals you know
maybe that was what was going on but you
know they told me I was like you know
that was just earthquake now cuckoo's
Theory actually makes sense on this side
of eternals now that we know shortly
after the events of end game there was
an escalation of earthquakes that
signaled the emergence of teammates but
to share my indulgent wish list with you
I want to see now more team up with
geographically diverse Heroes and
anti-heroes like Kenyan royalty Aurora
Monroe storm a mutant who needs to be
among the first batch of mutant titles
on Marvel Studios calendar like nothing
against these Wonder Man in Covenant
chaos announcements but can we just
please please just release a poster with
o-r-o-r-o and a Navy destroyer in the
midst of capsizing I mean that would get
like a billion subscribers to Disney
plus and I bring this up because there's
an age of X crossover event in which
storm and Neymar technically get married
which really pisses off t'challa but
their romance is so dangerous that both
of these mutants agree to wipe their
memories to erase the affair from their
minds by the high priest of the panther
Cult of wakanda also I believe we assume
namora must be near a body of water the
Florida Everglades are wet and a number
main thing team up doesn't that make
sense especially if you consider the
next time we see Neymar might be in
Avengers Kang Dynasty or Secret Wars
name or a man thing maybe especially
deadly duo in the swampy region of
battle world but really at the end of
the day now more is old both in his
Comics history and in the history of the
MCU the history of talocon predates the
present era of superheroes in the MCU
and Amor like the eternals witnessed the
horrors of human history evidenced by
early trailer footage showing a Haitian
plantation house so among the mutants
technically not more is at the very
least the Elder of them at least until
apocalypse is introduced but you know
what you had your chance eternals given
to Moore's political position against
humankind seeing them as corrupt
co-occupants of this planet Earth I
think no more it would be a solid choice
to be phase five father of the mcu's
mutant Brotherhood someone to at least
keep Magneto's seat warm maybe head up a
faction that Magneto could join forces
with now that the debate over superhero
privacy has re-entered the conversation
she-hulk's Daredevil episode the MCU is
ready to try to force all these recently
spawned enhanced individuals to register
mutants do not want to do that it's
cruel to do that who do they think
they're going to round them up to make
them register agents of the dodc no
you're going to need Sentinels for that
I truly believe that's where this is all
headed and I think leading the effort
against that Superhero registration
voicing the Magneto side of this
argument should be Namor because he's
already started that war you can follow
me on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at
boss follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new Rockstar for more analysis of every
thing you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you